I'm going to start out with farming yes
you grew up on a farm what's the
importance of farming
well I think it's the the balance
between physical and mental and so that
if you're farming it's not just rote
labor but you're thinking
how how much money am I losing today how
much money or I'm coming in today what's
the value of my labor as far as the
year-end bottom line
or how can I improve uh the pruners and
the vineyard with me should this person
be working over there so you're thinking
all the time but then you're working all
the time physical and if you if you're
too physical and you become rudish and
if you're too intellectual you become a
feat
so it's a perfect balance it was and
it's practical very
and it makes you very self-reliant
because uh there's nobody else but you
you keep saying am I going to get a
paycheck this week it depends on the
weather it depends on labor it depends
on things you can't calibrate
you know you don't know why certain
plums ripen at certain times you you
think you know but then it surprises you
so there's always the unpredictable
that kind of creates a humility that you
can't control things that you're
kind of a tragedy there's a tragedy
there that you cannot control but you
have to prepare for it because you never
know when you're going to lose a crop or
something on tour it'll happen
uh in my family one generation up
everybody was a farmer
and by the time they've all died or
retired
and I think one of their 14 children and
the two families above me one was a
farmer yeah and that's what's happened
what did that change the country it has
the founders
1776 95 percent of the constituents the
people living in the United what is that
was then going to be the United States
were farmers and by the 1920s it was
about 45 now it's one percent
I think Jefferson said when people are
all piled up in the cities it's not
going to work anymore
tocqueville seemed to think that the
reason In 1832 that things worked with
you had all of these autonomous people
and they were not like European peasants
they weren't
suburb subservient or they didn't they
were not serfs or they were not Hard
Scrabble
indentured renters or something but they
were autonomous I think that's really
that was very important doesn't mean
that it can't be transferred
that autonomy you can have independent
truck drivers you can have small
business people but you need a lot of
people who are not dependent on the
government or a big Corporation and that
type of confidence that accrues from
that they're they're very good citizens
and they're practical and they're Common
Sense the the difference with farming
was it had a natural component you can
really see it with things like climate
change
or scientific research quote-unquote or
government policy on nature written or
directed or
promulgated by people who don't have
anything to do with nature other than
just venture out on the weekends or
something and if they're not living with
nature they don't really understand it
and especially if they don't make their
living predicated on harnessing nature
but not harming nature it's kind of a
partnership
but they romanticize nature because
nature they're not dependent on nature
uh it uh of course we live
better by many measures than we lived
when everybody was a farmer
uh
are you suggesting there's a cost we
have to pay in order to live like that
I don't know I I as I I turned 70
yesterday and I had a grandfather who I
live in his bedroom and he lived in the
bedroom of his great grandmother so
there's six Generations
he died in this room when he was 86 and
his wife my grandmother I took care of
she died at 93 they had three daughters
they died at 49 my mother died at 66 and
her sister died at 60.
and then
um
I had a sister-in-law that died at 49
another her sister died at 54 and I had
a daughter that died at 26. and they all
grew up in this farm and then they went
out stressful jobs
and they my grandparents stayed there
and they got up they had a routine and I
don't think they ever went more than 100
miles they went to New Mexico one time
in their life but they had a a certain
cyclical idea and so you would they
would say things today that seemed
absurd there's a south wind blowing you
better be careful the birds are in the
trees
this is the phase of the moon and they
were attuned to they lived by nature and
the cycles and they had Diaries an
almanac they kept for 50 years and you
could look at the day and they would
pretty much tell you what you had to do
that day based on what they had done
that day 40 years in a row
so I think that must have had something
to do with longevity but they did pay a
price in the sense that they were
constantly apprehensive
about they had to live one more day they
didn't know where the income was coming
in the Razor Edge as far as the margin
of profitability and unprofitability but
there was something about staying in one
place and I think some of the worst
times I've had it's getting into this
and you was present no better than I do
the flying here or the flying there and
getting detached from being one in one
place and stationary and I think it's
not good for people
so uh one piece of advice for young
people might be uh
spend some time throughout your life
doing something real yeah do something
real and
cultivate family I think that's
important that don't just say that
that's my sister so that we're close or
that's my best friend so we're close
it's sort of farmers they tend to
maintain relationships or friendships a
long time because everybody knows what
they are are what they do where they're
going to be and they're not going to
move suddenly you're going to lose them
so that I think that was important uh
my uh to me a farm growing up uh my
father was the first one to go to
college in either family and so we lived
in the city that is to say Pocahontas 6
000 people
but uh I would go to the farm and to me
the farm was a playground
to all my aunts and uncles and my
parents at the farm was work work work
work work
and uh
they missed it and they didn't both yeah
but they had something real the
connection they'd worked in the fields
together as little kids yeah I have an
ambiguous relationship because I saw it
bankrupt a lot of people in my family
but on the other hand
I lived there and so if I walk out I'll
see a horseshoe in the dirt if I'm
digging or I'll see a remnant of
somebody or I'll see a barn that I
remember somebody being there when I was
five the exact same place
kind of haunts you you're in a house and
you can think of every room or every
window where somebody from the 19th
century they even talk different they
had different accents and they had
different vocabularies and you can
remember all of that and you do kind of
dumb things I have eight eight buildings
on around my house there's an old shed
there's a barn and they should have been
all been torn down they were built
1870 to 1880 with eucalyptus poles
and so I found myself the last few years
flying all over the country to speak to
get money than to rebuild these things
that there's no purpose for other than
my grandfather would say I'd really like
to have these buildings in good shape
one day well now they're all in good
shape but I don't use them the place
looks beautiful but it's only because I
wasn't farming I was farming they
wouldn't be there they would have been
banking so great
so
the classics
you have spent a lot of time studying
the ancient world
and you know the languages
well that's hard I've heard you say it
takes two thousand hours to become
competent in ancient Greek
I I came up with that number because I
used to teach a lot of minority kids for
20 years in Classics and I had to make
the argument to their parents
so I would say you know there's 52 weeks
a year
and you're going to have to spend if you
did 10 hours a week it wouldn't be
enough it'd be 500 but you could it's
going to be two thousand dollars you can
do it in two years three years but
ultimately you're gonna have to spend
that amount of tower uh
to learn Latin Greek I I went to a kind
of an ossified classical Believe It or
Not Stanford was the Harvard in those
days was the classical philology
Department it wasn't ancient history it
wasn't archeology it wasn't art history
it wasn't comparatively it was just pure
language and we had to learn how to read
and write in Greek and Latin take
dictation and Greek and lot and take
courses in manually it was very narrow I
remember my brother was kind of a smart
uh smart alec very brilliant guy and I
came home
and my father said what did you learn
and he said he's like Samuel Johnson's
dog he can walk on two legs it's very
interesting but we don't know the
purpose of it he thought that was what
Greek was he said he can write Greek and
Latin and then my dad said well that'll
do you good I want you to go over and
wire a raisin dehydrator with 220 and
rebuild it and I said I'm not sure I can
do that he said if you can spend all
this time reading Greek you should learn
how to do that
and he didn't give me any instruction he
just said go do it and then I can see
your education is valuable that's great
so I had to how did the interest in that
Dawn in you
it was just an accident I was from a
farm and I went to University of Santa
California Santa Cruz it was kind of a
hippie it just opened it was supposedly
the place everybody wanted to go my
father picked it because all three of us
got in he thought it would be cheaper
and we could all live together in a
rental house
and I was in a class and there was this
wonderful Professor named John Lynch and
I did pretty well on a western sieve and
he said would you like to study Latin
Greek I said no my mother had grown up
on the farm and she was a lawyer a judge
at that time and I thought wow I want to
be a lawyer and then he said you're
doing pretty well why didn't you go take
Yale uh go to Yale summer school and
take Greek after your freshman year and
I said
I'm only 18 and you said Well
everybody's in their late 20s if you
survive that intensive Greek program and
it was pretty traumatic for me I'd never
been out of California so then I started
doing pretty well I came back and I it
was he that whole Classics group at UC
Santa Cruz had come from Yale and they
were philologists believe it or not
so when I graduated
he was always telling now you can go to
Greece so my parents would come home and
said what are you going to do with this
and I said I don't know I'm pretty good
at it and they always give me money
so then
I applied to graduate school and she
said well she was a Stanford chauvinist
my grandfather had mortgages his farm
and sent two of his girls to Stanford to
get Bas and advanced Greece and she said
well we're a Stanford family I said I'm
not going to go there
and then I asked this my my mentor and
he said yeah they have a really good
philology department and they'll pay
your entire way if you could get in so
they had examinations to take and then I
was 25 and I looked at the job market
and there was no jobs for a white male
that knew Latin and Greek so I came home
to take care of my grandparent my
grandmother for a summer and the next
thing I knew I stayed five years farming
full-time and then at some point
I didn't have any money I wasn't doing
too well and there was a campus at Cal
State Fresno I never really been there
30 miles away and I walked in and asked
if I could teach a Latin class and they
said they'll think about it for three
years
first day I got there I parked on campus
and the secretary said I had tracked mud
in because I was irrigating
and going back and forth and then the
next thing I did I went out to the
parking lot and there were the police
were there around my pickup
Mr what's your name and I said Hanson he
said what do you do and you have a
shotgun in the window
and that's against the law to have a
State campus is the get is the firearm
loaded and I said yeah I shoot things
that on the farm I don't remember when a
coyote and they didn't believe that I
was a faculty member and they're very
nice guy I got to know him really well
he said I didn't see any of this to put
the gun tuck it better down
and never bring it on campus again that
was my first day at Clint campus
that was 20 years I stayed there so it
got better
[Music]